I was posing for the thumbnail I
shouldn't have this in the thumbnail
should I it's it's not real I feel like
this video gets flagged if I had it in
thumbnails I'm not gonna do it pistols
are so bad the equalizer too so
equalizer 2 is the sequel to the
equalizer that enjoyable movie in which
Denzel plays a badass so now he's back
snapping more arms breaking more bones
keep in time he will clear out of room
30 seconds or less that's pretty much
this movie in a nutshell he does stuff
he helps people
he's a lyft driver who helps people so
it's kind of like a superhero that's
mainly what it is there is an
overarching story there's like the main
story in here and among the main story
you have your side quest in which case
he's helping other people too and what I
liked about this movie is Denzel dude's
great he's a master of his craft and I'm
glad he could still kick ass the way he
does what I love most about it is he
always seems so collected just his
character just walk up to you talk in
your face and that very calm collected
Denzel voice and you're scared out of
your mind you know this guy can break
every bone in your body with two
thoughts
Denzel being the equalizer those are the
enjoyable parts of the movie when the
action is going down it's great it's
top-notch it's like watching John wick
only different character now what I
didn't like is the basic formation of
this movie or the lack thereof I feel
like this movie lacks focus or
directions like I said the main plot is
in there the setup happens early on in
the movie there's just a series of
Denzel doing things and then it
addresses it again in a series of Denzel
is just very messy the best way I can
describe it it played out like a video
game take a video game with side quests
are GTA whatever you have the main plot
then you have the side quest you can
pick up these side quests and do them
but if you do too many of these side
quests in between doing the main
storyline you start to forget what the
main storyline is like I got to do the
main quest oh yeah and you get a
refresher and it works great for a video
game you're clocking in more hours
you're getting your money's worth is
replay value doesn't translate well to a
movie if you look at the main plot which
if I'm being honest or fair the movie
does focus up on it in the last third
maybe happen it's cliche as hell at a
point in this movie you're gonna be like
hmm I wonder how this is gonna go down
which I feel like I would roll with the
cliche a story like this if it kept me
interested and didn't feel so sloppy I
mean really the most interesting plot in
this movie is one of the side plots he's
trying to keep this kid out of a gang I
was more enthralled with that than the
main story some of the side plots were
better than the main block I'm the side
plots we're not I don't care about the
old guy in his
painting I don't this movie just had so
much in it it felt like it was a season
of television crushed into two hours
which I've said about a couple of movies
before but it's applicable then it's
applicable now those side plot
storylines that exist to kill time
granted I also know that they do exist
to add character and depth to denzel's
character but it doesn't do that as much
as it is there to fill time those work
in a season a television you take any
season a television there are always
those episodes that are episodic in
which case they're not really tie-in to
the main plot they just they exist to be
their own contained thing when you have
a two-hour movie you don't really have
time for that as in the end the
equalizer too has some good moments in
it but the unfocused stitching and
editing that tied all the side plots
into the main plot made the main plot
kind of feel less relevant until the
main plot was more relevant in the
second half or really for the first half
of the movie or like where we go into a
fan encases sequel itis on rare
occasions a sequel will surpass the
first sometimes the sequel is even as
good as the first but most time the
sequel is just not as good as the first
and that's the case of the equalizer -
I'll say I'm just not gonna remember
this movie in t-minus one day yep
already forgot all right so the
equalizer - have you seen it what did
you think about it or what's your
favorite Denzel role ever whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]